bueno digamos que la manifestación es
hoy en día por supuesto intervinieron un
día después de de este ataque en París
con una comunidad que está muy
movilizada no hablamos de cualquier
comunidad en Francia hablamos de la
comunidad curda con un contexto
geopolítico que explica esa tensión que
explica esa cólera que pueden tener
lógicamente después de ese ataque de que
provocó tres muertos geopolítica porque
los kurdos reivindican pues
territorios en medio oriente tocando
países en el centro del eje
internacional
Turquía obviamente y por otra parte se
inscribió ese ataque en un contexto diez
años después de otro ataque que había
matado tres activistas en París y se iba
a celebrar ese ese drama ocurrió hace
diez años es decir pues que había un
contexto ahora que se propague esas
manifestaciones No sé lo veremos en los
próximos días yo no creo Creo que es una
comunidad muy movilizada hoy en día y en
ese contexto de tensión que vimos en
París Pues bueno porque estas
manifestaciones se transforman es decir
inician de forma pacífica y luego
terminan en violencia es decir los
choques tienen un propósito Más allá de
expresar la ira por lo que ocurrió
pues ahí podemos preguntarnos
definitivamente es la razón por la cual
le decía que la comunidad kurda No es
cualquier comunidad hay este contenido
político un contenido identitario un
contenido histórico un contenido de
violencia que vimos digamos a través de
la fuerza de ese ataque primero y
obviamente con esa movilización de
manifestaciones ahora es cierto nos
podemos preguntar por qué violencia Por
qué unos grupos minoría intervienen Y
por qué vemos
sistemáticamente en cualquier
manifestación hoy en día en Francia pero
en demás países también esos actos de
violencia porque sí puede aparecer
grupos organizados que están aquí
apareciendo para hacer
revelar pues una violencia en un
contexto creo que eso es muy importante
muy particular geopolítico pero también
obviamente en en política nacional
cuándo ocurrió ayer ese drama Obviamente
todos pensamos en los atentados de 2015
en en lo que ocurrió tanto con enero del
2015 como en noviembre es decir que
existe ese esa pantalla de fondo que
puede explicar también pues Ese temor
pero aquí ocurrió contra una comunidad
en un sitio muy particular en el centro
cultural kurdo de París es decir pues y
la investigación revelará si todavía es
solamente un acto racista como hoy en
día lo lo dice la investigación O sí
también pasaremos como lo quisiera
reivindicar la la comunidad kurda a un
acto terrorista